there's nothing there is worthy of
worship where we worship in truth in
truth except Allah accept Allah another
Witness
the Muhammad the Muhammad is the last
messenger is the last message and the
servant of Allah
bless you bro congratulations
research and he said this division
happened the question before us and to
the Jewish people to the Jews before us
he said all of them deserves to be
punished with the four except one they
said Allah he said while I'm on today
and my companions so after the kill of
ultimately so after Prophet Muhammad
passed away the leader that came after
him
then
offend so all during all that time the
Muslims were one
Nation
one all of them following the same
belief same methodology after the
killing of Usman
the Muslims are divided into groups yeah
so Prophet Muhammad taught us and that's
from his prophecies because he mentioned
something during his lifetime there was
no groups or sects you know all Muslims
were seen in belief same in methodology
so the first group that came out from
the main body recorded Arabic
to give you example like Isis our time
you know they just they kill innocent
people claiming doing Jihad you know
about Jihad yeah yeah which
Jihad was legislated not to bring about
corruption Islam
that one when you go outside Islam was
legislated to remove the tyrants
not to kill innocent people you know so
so then the Shia came out Shia the
extreme Ali one of the Prophet Muhammad
even believe he was God and you know so
there was other groups no doubts but
what distinguished Islam from Christian
to Judaism Islam still have the criteria
been preserved like Christianity now all
the groups that exist within
Christianity none of them can tell you
who's following the truth because the
criteria that are utilizing is corrupted
you know for example imagine we have
like uh I don't know like imagine we're
building a wall
all of us we lived in the world and they
say about world is straight he said his
word straight and he said okay all of us
to know which world is straight let us
utilize the the measurements yeah but
guess what the measurement that we're
using is 40.
so so there's nothing to utilize them in
the stand so say Judaism but Islam the
criteria is still preserved and it's
perfect and it's valid so how do we know
who's following the truth or is not we
go back to the Quran it's been preserved
the prophet prophetic traditions we
preserved likewise that the teaching and
the understanding of his disciples be
preserved so this call itself is
self-eating an Arabic language called
means someone that follow the pious
predecessors who are they Prophet
Muhammad and his companions and also for
their students and their students the
three durations called asale
so in Arabic for example you're from
Grenada
or like Algeria I don't say I am Algeria
I say I am Algerian and Arabic I said
yes
I'm ascribing myself to the country so
when you come to is
someone that follows
who are they like I mentioned Prophet
Muhammad and his companions and their
students and their students so this is
what he means salafi and there's other
groups but they are not following the
truth and uh of course they're still
Muslims no doubts yes and uh but why
they don't follow the truth because you
know people like for their desires some
people they look to follow uh to make
the truth with the falsehood but Prophet
Muhammad told us there will be a group
of ummah of my nation manifesting upon
the truth and thou not be harmed by the
harmed by those oppose them or those who
betray them until Allah shall come to
pass so what we see now the difference
is that is occurring and is taking place
amongst the Muslims Prophet Muhammad
told us about it and it's a disease no
doubt differences division is disease
but he told us the Cure
left us upon a clear guidance what is
upon us to do study
seek knowledge knowledge is very
powerful you know there's one of the
powerful statements from the cousin of
the Prophet Muhammad
his name he said knowledge is better
than wealth
knowledge is better than wealth why
because the knowledge protects you as
for the wealth you protected
so when you have a knowledge if someone
come try to manipulate you or misguide
you you have the knowledge to protect
yourself in the Sun so for example
imagine someone comes to you say listen
let's go blow up ourselves in the train
this this Jihad says
Allah told us and Prophet Muhammad told
us don't kill innocent people
and Allah told us people should not be
responsible for other people's sins
if someone comes to kill my sister I'm
not gonna go
if someone killed my sister I'm not
allowed to go kill his sister because
his sister has not been doing it
you know or his mother you know so this
is
so just study learn step by step but
like I said knowledge is very important
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
Allah